hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the article corporate governance and
ethics a feminist perspective one of the
topics that of course needs to be
addressed and it is towards the end of
the article is well what would feminist
corporate governance actually look like
what would what would the application of
feminist values and feminist Theory and
women's experiences and the ethics of
care what would that bring to
organizations so one of the key aspects
that's that's discussed before going
into the final section of a governance
model is how organizations could be
reconceptualized there's a lot of
different ways in which organizations
can be
depicted or thought about or modeled
and very often we'll look at say the
table of organization and who reports to
who or things like that and that does
capture some aspect of relationships
but that only captures some portions of
it that's sort of the structure of
reporting or you might you know look at
task management
any organization is actually a much
wider network of relationships people
talking to each other in the lunchroom
for example
co-workers who happen to have gone to
the same school and chit chat with each
other for that reason and and so it's
not simply about the the ways in which
organizations have traditionally been
conceived they are in fact networks now
a key question that comes up is well is
it possible for organizations even if
they're understood as networks of
relationships can they the kinds of
entities that they are can they care
or is that something that's only uh
possible for individuals in relationship
with each other
and there's some skepticism about this
uh for example Nell noddings uh is is
you know quite skeptical about the
possibility of extending an ethics of
care to institutions or Nation States or
other or you know organizations of human
beings
but organizations are not as the authors
are pointing out just abstract entities
they're not just boxes that you put a
bunch of things into they're made up of
individuals and those individuals are
going to have varying degrees of care
orientation either deliberately or as
part of their their background and
upbringing and education so
if you've got individuals then doesn't
that mean that the organization itself
can care well the answer is a little bit
more complicated than that and here we
bring in what we call necessary and and
sufficient conditions
so
caring individuals are in necessary
condition for having a caring
organization you can't have a caring
organization without actual people doing
caring you've got to have somebody on
the ground floor so to speak right
you've got to have people representing
the organization in their activities so
that's a necessary condition
it's not a sufficient condition and this
is something that many people experience
within organizations uh they find
themselves being affected quite
negatively by the fact that they're
they're caring sometimes puts them at a
disadvantage you know think about for
example call centers where you have a
certain quota that you're supposed to
meet and you have customers calling in
with problems now if you're going to be
empathetic with them and listen to their
story instead of saying well listen I
got a quota I got to cut through this
narrative tell me what your problem is
Buddy so I can you know delegate it to
the right person or give you the right
you know tutorial or something like that
if you're not being caring you might be
able to process a lot more costs yeah
customers and then therefore meet your
quotas but if you are being caring even
though that should be a value of the
business you may be at a disadvantage
so it's not a sufficient condition what
what's required what's needed in order
to actively support Care on the
um
part of those caring individuals and so
lidka suggests that a caring
organization in addition to being
composed of individuals who meet the
conditions of being caring would need to
actively support their efforts through
its goals systems strategies and values
and it's not enough just to have it in
the mission statement we care about our
customers that means that if somebody
needs to spend more time on the line
there need to be some sort of procedures
for clicking a button and saying listen
supervisor I'm not going to meet my
quota today but I'm doing something
that's good for the company and good for
the customer and this should be
respected and the cut the company should
allow for that that sort of thing if it
doesn't then you've got a significant
problem this is a major issue when it
comes to handling customer complaints
and problems but you can think about how
this would affect sales you're going to
think about how this might affect the
inner workings of the company as well
how training and mentoring and coach
would work so there's a lot involved
here
what would a feminist corporate
governance model actually look like
there's there's a number of different
features that get picked out in this
this paper so one is that it does not
limit the scope of relationships that it
cares about simply to whether they're
contractual or not or fiduciary or not
so as a feminist governance model
recognizes a multiplicity of actual and
potential relationships with varying
degrees of asymmetry in power
distribution within which there is an
obligation to care so that that's
another key point that we're going to
hit on another is that it prioritizes
all individuals not just some but all
individuals
with whom a relationship uh is
established whether in the past a
relationship has been established a
relationship is being established in the
present or a relationship could be
established in the future so if we think
about how this would affect uh
stakeholder uh analysis and theory if
you're proposing say releasing pollution
into the environment you are now going
to have a relationship with everybody
affected by that right and you have a
duty to care not to damage their uh
environment even if it has to do with
like you know impinging on uh the the
Fauna of the Flora sorry of walking
paths what the fauna matters too as well
right Flora plants fauna animals there's
also an obligation to care this is
absolutely Central so the so they said a
universal principle underpinning the
governance relationships all the
relationships within the structure of
the the company is the obligation to
care a sense of responsibility in
individuals within and outside the
organization to nurture others and they
give a really great example of this here
uh talking about
managers learning about the background
and identity of those within their
immediate care understanding the
individual's need for job satisfaction
or a work-life balance and empathizing
with it now think about how
transformative that would be for so many
workplaces if managers actually held
themselves to that sort of standard they
also do point out this doesn't mean as
they use the word Molly coddling people
right this doesn't mean being a pushover
but this does mean relating to people as
another person as an individual
another key thing is embedding care
within internal and external systems and
procedures of the company it's not
enough to have caring individuals it's
not enough to have caring managers it
needs to be made part of the structure
of the company and it's it probably
needs to be reinforced over and over
again by management and management who
aren't just Hypocrites talking the talk
about that but actively supporting here
unfortunately in so many institutions we
see the language of care being used but
not being embodied by the management or
the executive leadership
uh finally caring this is a very
important Point caring must not be
limited to a select group and the
example that they use there is of
managers
so you can't you know have a caring
organization where the managers are
really well taken care of and supported
you know people inquire about their work
life balance and how their kids are
doing and all all that sort of stuff but
the employees are cut out of it that is
not going to work as a matter of fact
that's just simply reinforcing uh you
know sort of traditional structures
you also couldn't do it just favoring
the workers either and ignoring
management nor could you do it by giving
such great customer service that you
make things so difficult for management
and employees right everybody matters
another one that I think could be a
particularly tempting Prospect
especially if resources are scarce is
focusing on high performers we need to
really be really supportive of these
high performers and make sure that they
feel uh you know entirely taken care of
that they're cared for we're empathetic
to their problems but screw everybody
else they they don't really matter uh
you know a great example of of this sort
of mentality would be
um the the you know famous line from
Glengarry Glenn Ross coffee is for
closers that that embodies that now
they're not very caring in that movie I
advise you to take a look at it as well
but um if you if you think about it that
notion of well we're going to provide
things for you we're going to provide a
supportive environment but only if
you're performing that's not really the
ethics of care now again it's not to say
that that people can be strung along
indefinitely uh being taken care of
within a business environment sooner or
later everybody has to produce but the
ethics of care would embody some sort of
you know mentoring coaching
developmental process that embodied all
of these these aspects so that is what
corporate governance would look like if
it was truly informed by feminist ethics